قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع تتحمل في المقام الاول
مسؤوليه القيام بما وصفته بالفضاء في
دارفور واتهمت الوزاره في بيان لها قوات
الجيش بالتقصير في حمايه المدنيين مشيره
الى انتشار العنف الجنسي واعمال القتل على
اساس عرقي ودعا البيان الى وقف القتال
مؤكدا استمرار واشنطن مع شركائها لتحقيق
ذلك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلالات الكيفيه
التي وزعت بها واشنطن المسؤوليات على سقوط
عدد كبير من الضحايا جراء احداث العنف في
دارفور مخاطبه من خلال ذلك طرفي الازمه في
البلاد كيف يمكنني طرفي الازمه ومن
يدعمهما في الداخل والخارج والجهات
المعنيه بجهود التسويه في السودان ان
تتفاعل مع هذه الرؤيه الامريكيه خاصه
والخارجيه عامه للمشهد في السودان ما هي
فرص المواقف الخارجيه الداعيه لوقف القتال
والبحث عن تسويه سلميه للنزاعات في التحول
الى ورقه ضغط فاعله لتحقيق ذلك بالنظر الى
تعقيدات وتطورات الازمه
[موسيقى]
في محطه جديده من المسار الذي اتخذه
الخطاب الامريكي وحيال الازمه في السودان
والتطورات الداميه في ولايه غربي دارفور
تحدثت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان
لها بشكل اوضح عن كل ذلك فاتهمت طرفي
النزاع بارتكاب انتهاكات وان حملت قوات
الدعم القسم الاكبر منها بيان ذكر بما
شهدته ولايه دارفور في سنوات سابقه من
فضاعات ارتقت الى درجه الاباده الجماعيه
الامر الذي اثار سؤاله حول ما اذا كان
البيان مقدمه لمرحله جديده من التعامل
الامريكي مع الملف السوداني بتعقيداته
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ماثيو
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ماثيو
ميلر اعرب مجددا عن خيبه امر بلاده من
افعال طرفي الصراع في السودان وقال ان
بلاده تواصل العمل مع شركائها لانهاء
العنف في البلاد
شعرنا بخيبه امل كبيره ازاء افعال الطرفين
ونحن مستمرون في الوقوف مع الشعب السوداني
ونحث الطرفين على وقف اطلاق النار فورا
مستمرون في العمل بشان السودان بشكل ثنائي
ومع شركائنا في المنطقه خاصه السعوديه
كانت احدى رسائلنا المباشره للطرفين
واعلنا انه لا يوجد حل عسكري لهذا الصراع
مباحثات جده وفرت فرصه لاجراء حوار وجها
لوجه ونحث الطرفين بقوه على الاستفاده من
ذلك
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من ميشيق الناس
سفيره سوزان بيج نائبه مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق للشؤون
الافريقيه
والمستشاره السابقه للمبعوث الامريكيه
الخاصه الى السودان ومن باريس محمد تورشين
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني اهلا
وسهلا بكما
السفيره
كيف نفهم البيان الامريكي الذي تحدث عن عن
الوضع في السودان وحمل كما يبدو قوات
الدعم السريع المسؤوليه في المقام الاول
كما جاء في البيان وان قال ايضا ان الجيش
مسؤول عن فضائعات ارتكبوا في دارفور
نعم شكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه الكريمه
اولا يمكنني ان اقول بالنسبه الى هذا
البيان من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن
نتحدث عن نقطه ايجابيه بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
تسمي قوات الدعم السريع ولكن في الوقت
نفسه اشار البيان كما قلتم ان الجيش
السوداني مسؤول عن فضائع بالاضافه الى عدم
حمايه المدنيين في دارفور وفي ارجاء
البلاد المختلفه وبالتالي لا نصدم اذا ما
استمعنا الى هكذا بيان ولكنها المره
الاولى التي اشارت فيها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بهذه الطريقه الى طرفي النزاع
نعم ولكن يعني ما دلاله هذا البيان
بالطريقه التي صيغ بها وبالطريقه التي
تحدث بها عن قوات الدعم السريع وعن الجيش
وعن قوله ان قوات الدعم السريع هي
المسؤوله في المقام الاول
ماذا يخبرنا ذلك عن الفهم الامريكي
والقراءه الامريكيه لما يحدث في السودان
نعم ما قامت به الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من خلال هذا البيان عبر وزاره
الخارجيه تكرر صدى التقارير الوارده من
الميدان من منظمات سودانيه عامله في
الميدان بالاضافه الى مجموعات مراقبه في
السودان
وجهات فاعله اخرى من مثل وكالات الامم
المتحده والوكالات الاغاثيه والانسانيه في
الميدان هناك عدد من التقارير حول شهود
عيان نتحدث عن انتهاكات للقانون الانساني
الدولي وبالتالي من الواضح ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تصغي وتعرف ما يحصل في
الميدان ما تراه هو ان قوات الدعم السريع
مسؤوله بشكل اكبر عن هذه الانتهاكات ضد
القانون الانساني الدولي وبال الى ذلك
اشار البيان الى مسؤوليه الجيش السوداني
بالنسبه الى الفضاءات وايضا في الوقت نفسه
فشل الجيش في حمايه المدنيين في مناطق
النزاع المختلفه وهو ما التزم به الطرفان
في جده اضافه الى ذلك هناك نقصا في
الالتزام من كلى الطرفين وبالاضافه الى
ذلك اشارت الى استمرار النزاع سيد محمد
طرشين هل نجح البيان في رسم صوره واضحه
لما يحدث بالضبط في السودان في دارفور
بشكل خاص وفي عموم البلاد في السودان
في البدايه التحيه لك ولضيفتك الكريمه
وللسائر المشاهدين الكرام انا في تقدير
الموقف الامريكي اتى متاخرا جدا بالرغم من
ان الارهاصات وكذلك الكثير من المعلومات
كانت متوفره للاداره الامريكيه بمعنى ان
السياره السفير الامريكيه تم استهدافها من
اوائل السيارات او اوائل الفيروسات
الدبلوماسيه ايضا التي تم استهدافها في
الخرطوم من قبل قوات الدعم السريع فضلا عن
ذلك الكثير من الارهاصات والمؤشرات تؤكد
بان الدعم السريع هو متورط في ارتكاب
جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه سواء كان
ايذاء المدنيين باحتمائه في منازلهم وكذلك
ايقاف الخدمات الطبيه في المستشفيات وما
الى ذلك لكن ربما هذا
البيان الامريكي الذي صور مؤخرا كان هنالك
بعض الحسابات التي تدعى ان تحققها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامر الذي
طرح عده تساؤلات هل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت تصبو او كانت لديها مقاربه
ومخترفه بمحاوله ان تجعل هنالك تساوي بين
الجيش والدعم السريع او لديها رؤيه بان
بان تاتي فرصه لاعاده هيكله الجيش
السوداني بهذه العمليات العسكريه انا في
تقديري بالرغم ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت متحمسه في ازمه دارفور وهي
التي ساعد بشكل كبير جدا باحاله الجرائم
التي ارتكبت في دارفور الى المحكمه
الجنائيه هذه الخطوه انا في تقدير ستفتح
الباب امام العديد من القوه الاقليميه
والدوليه ان تصرح صراحه بان الجهات التي
قامت بالاعتداء على البعثات الدبلوماسيه
في الخرطوم هي الدعم السريع والكاميرات
موجوده والاقمار الصناعيه وما الى ذلك
فبالتالي هذه الله التصريحات او هذا
البيان الصادر من الله من الخارجيه
الامريكيه فضلا عن العقوبات التي صدرت من
الخزانه الامريكيه
ستفتحولات كبيره جدا لازما ان الكثير من
القوى الاقليميه كانت تنتظر رده فعل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانا في تقدير
بهذا البيان
القوات المسلحه [__] لا تحقق مكاسب بمعنى
ان تحملها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اخفاقها في حمايه المدنيين بمعنى ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعترف بالجيش
هو المؤسسه الشرعيه والرزميه المنوط بها
حمايه المدنيين في هذه الجزيره ربما تجعل
القوات المسلحه ان تتدارك الاخطاء التي
ارتكبتها بعدم التحرك بجدها لحمايه
المدنيس وكان في الجنينه او في نياله او
في اعتبار هذه المناطق ظلت محاصره تظلت
هنالك جمله من الالتهابات ايذاء المدنيين
قوات الدعم سيده سوزان بيج البيان تحدث عن
ارتكاب جرائم على اساس
عرقي على ايضا جرائم
جنسيه عنف جنسي
لوحه باعتبار ذلك جرائم اباده جماعيه هل
يعني هذا بالضروره ان هناك ربما تغيرا في
الموقف في الامريكي بمعنى ان هذا البيان
له
ما بعده ما دام قد تحدث بهذه الصيغه
بكل تاكيد نعم اذا ما يشير اليه البيان هو
ان الفضاءات ارتكبت في دارفور بشكل اساسي
من قبل قوات الدعم السريع والمليشيات
التابعه لها ولكن كلا الطرفين يتحملان
المسؤوليه وبالتالي يشير البيان بشكل اكبر
الى مسؤوليه قوات الدعم السريع بنسبه الى
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
والخروقات المختلفه ولكن البيان لا يستثني
الجيش السوداني من المسؤوليه البيان يوضح
ان كلا الطرفين ارتكباه الفضائع ولكن من
بين الامور التي تبعث الى القلق وانا اتفق
مع الزميل الاخر فيما قاله بهذا الخصوص
اذا بالنسبه الى التعامل مع الطرفين بنفس
الطريقه وعلى قدم المساواه هذا لم ياتي
بالفائده في السودان ولكن بالنسبه الى
الاعتراف بالجيش السوداني على انه القوه
الشرعيه المسؤوله هذا لربما غير دقيق لانه
ولا اي طرف من الطرفين لديه الشرعيه لان
الشرعيه اتت بين مزدوجين الشرعيه اتت بعد
الانقلاب لذلك بالنسبه الى ما حدث بعد
الرباعيه هناك
مصالح مختلفه لجهات متعدده في المنطقه ومن
ضمن الرباعيه ولذلك اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحاول ان تسير بحذر
بينما تقوم به قوات الدعم السريعه من جهه
والجيش من جهه اخرى ومحاوله تفادي التدخل
بلدان بشكل سلبي من خلال ض المزيد من
المقاتلين في الميدان نرى استاذ محمد
هرشين يعني الى اي مدى هذا الكلام مهم
بالنسبه لك ولكثير من المتابعين
السودانيين عندما تقول السيده سوزان بيج
وهي يعني ليس لها منصب رسمي ولكنها كانت
مساعده لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابقه الشؤون الافريقيه
مستشاره سابقا للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص
بالسودان وتقول ان الاعتراف بان
المسؤول الشرعي هو الجيش هذا كلام غير
دقيق في الحقيقه كلا الطرفين ليس لهما
شرعيه حسب المنظور الامريكي الى اي مدى
هذا الكلام مهم للفاعلين في المشهد
السوداني
بلا شك الولايات وكثير من الله الانظمه لا
تعترف بالانظمه التي اتت عن طريق الحكم
بواسطه انقلابات عسكريه ومعلومه 25 اكتوبر
تم انقلاب على الوثيقه الدستوريه
العديد من التحفظات حولها لكن هذه هي
الحقيقه فبالتالي انا في تقدير الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تنظر الى الازمه في
السودان بشيء من اولا تنظر الى ان ذلك اذا
استمر النزاع بهذه التراتبيه وبهذه الله
التعقيد ربما يفتح الباب الى حضور منافسيه
سانقار روسيا والصين وفي الاتجاه الاخر
بتحاول انها تقارب بان الوضع الذي يجري في
السودان ان يتلائم مع مبادئ النظام
العالمي الجديد والتوجهات الامريكيه
المرتبطه بالديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
فبالتالي موقفت السفينه حاليا على تفهموا
تماما لكن نحن بنتحدث عن الجهه التي مرض
بها تحقيق الامن والاستقرار لا نتحدث عن
الحكومه لا احد مفاوض من قبل الشعب
السوداني سواء كانت الدعم السريعه الجيش
السوداني في هذه هي مؤسسات موجوده بشانها
شان المؤسسات الاخرى ينبغي ان تقوم بدورها
المنوط به او المنصوص عليه في الدستور
وكذلك في القانون اذا عرفنا ان نتحدث عن
النظام سي ان تنتهي هذه الحرب ومن بعد ان
تكون هنالك فتره زمنيه معلومه لقيام
انتخابات باعتبار ان هذه الازمه انا في
تقدير الان التي نعيشها بشكل او باخر
تتحمل المسؤوليتها القوه الاقليميه
والدوليه بمعنى القوى الاقليميه والدوليه
كانت غير الطواقه او متحمسه لاجراء
انتخابات في فتره وجيزه وعندما كنا نتحدث
عن انتخابات لا نتحدث عن انتخابات شامله
وانما نتحدث عن انتخاب جمعيه تشريعيه عند
ان تكون مهمتها سياقه الدستور وكذلك اجراء
تعديلات جوهريه في القانون ومن بعد تطرح
كل هذه اللاعب التعديلات الدستوريه
والقانونيه لاستفتاء شعبي جماهيري لكن
كانت هنالك القوه السياسيه التي تحكم
واعنق والحريه والتغيير لديها كانت رغبه
ان تستمر في الحكم بدون تفويض جماهير
حقيقي حتى تحقق مكاسب حزبيه ومكاسب سياسيه
فبالتالي الان هذا الموقف الامريكي متخبط
او
محاوله ان تجري الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مقارنه بين المبادئ وبعض
التوجهات الدوليه وكذلك مصالح الجيو
استراتيجيه لذا بنجد ان الموقف الامريكي
غير واضح او حاسم في كثير من التفاصيل
السيده سوزمبيج هناك كما قال البيان فضائع
ترتكب القتال الان مستمر والتحذيرات
الامميه
والامريكيه مستمره في حال تجاهل مثل هذه
البيانات الامريكيه هل هذا بيان من اجل
رفع العتب ام ربما الولايات المتحده قد
تتدخل بشكل
اكبر ربما بالتعاون مع اخرين حتى يصل
الامر الى تدخل عسكري ما هو سقف التدخل
الامريكي الذي يمكن ان يكون في هذه القضيه
ام سيقتصر الامر على بيانات من هذا النوع
في الحقيقه امل ان نشهد تدخلا اكثر من
البيانات لان الاوان قد ان لتخطي مرحله
البيانات وكما ذكر الضيف الكريم هناك
عقوبات ايضا وهناك شركات مرتبطه
بقوات الدعم السريع وايضا
بالقوات المسلحه طبعا هذا هذه خطوه في
الاتجاه الصحيح الضغط يجب ان يمارس على
الطرفين ولكن بكل تاكيد اذا مقاله
الولايات المتحده الان انا قوات الدعم
السريعه مسؤوله بشكل اكبر عن بعض
الانتهاكات يجب ان نرى ضغطا دوليا متزايدا
وبالتازر ليس فقط من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بل من الاسره الدوليه
لتفادي قصف البنى التحتيه المدنيه ولتركي
المستشفيات والتوقف عن اغتصاب النساء
الفضاءات
الكبيره
المرتكبه في مناطق النزاع المختلفه نحن
نتحدث عن نقاط خطره
المدنيون الان تحت رحمه هذه القوات بشكل
كامل سواء كانوا في الخرطوم او في دارفور
وفي المناطق المتاثره بالنزاعه ولكن في
خارج الخرطوم وام درمان والاماكن الاخرى
في السودان التي هي محاذيه للخرطوم وفي
دارفور قوات الدعم السريع ليس بالضروره ان
يكون لديه تاثير ونفوذ كبير ولكن لا نعرف
مدى تواجد الجيش السوداني في تلك المناطق
ولكن نامل ان تاتي الاسره الدوليه
بمساعدات انسانيه اكبر
للمنطقه النقطه الاخيره هي دور هيئه
الايجاد الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه وهي تؤدي
دورا اضافيا ومتزايدا اذا ما هي الصوره
بالنسبه الى
الهيئات الاقليميه والمنظمات الاقليميه ان
الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه لايجاد وهي منظمه
في منطقه القرن الافريقي
اتخذت المبادره وبدات العمل على اليات
مرتبطه بالازمه السودانيه في حال تم
البناء على هذه المبادرات بالعمل مع
الخبراء من خارج المنطقه للمراقبه ولتقديم
التوصيات يكون ذلك خطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح
ولكن يجب ان يتخطى الامر مجرد البيانات
للوصول الى خطوات عمليه لتحقيق التغيير
الديمقراطي الذي يدعو اليه الشعب السوداني
سيد محمد تورش ين هل يعني ما الذي تراه
يمكن ان يكون مفيدا
للضغط ربما على الطرفين
لايقاف هذه الحرب او التوصل الى تسويع ما
او حسم الامور بشكل او باخر في السودان هل
تعتقد ان هناك فرصه حقيقيه من خلال ما
يمكن ان تقوم به الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واطراف خارجيه اخرى
المسائل الامريكيه الحديثه وكذلك
الاقليميه وسواء كان الاجاده والاتحاد
الافريقي او حتى من برا جده كلها هي
مبادرات تفضي الى الى هدف واحد وهو عوده
الاوضاع الى الى ما كانت عليه من قبله هي
نوع من الاستقرار لكن انا في تقدير التحدي
الان بيكمن هل اللعب القوه الان التي تطرح
مبادرات بما في ذلك الايجارات هل لديها
تصور
يبقي الوضع الدستوري بشكل طبيعي بان يكون
هنالك جيش واحد وهنالك مؤسسات معلومه كما
موجوده في حال كل الدول ام هي تصورات
تحاول ان تعود بالاوضاع الى ما قبل اندلاع
هذه المواجهات بان يكون الدعم السريع هو
مؤسسه منفصله موجوده في حاله انا في تقدير
اذا كانت تصور بهذه
الشكليه او بهذه المنطقيه انا في تقديري
بمثابه تاجيل الحربي الى وقت لاحق لكن
عندما تكون المبادره الجاده تسمي الاشياء
باسمائها بان هذا وضع غير الدستوري وضع
شائه بان يتم دمج الدعم السريع في الجيش
السوداني في فتره وجيزه وان يكون ذلك عبر
استيفاء كل قواعد الدخول المؤسسه العسكريه
السودانيه وما الى ذلك وان تكون هنالك
مباحثات او مؤتمر للحوار وطني شامل يشمل
كل القوه السياسيه ان يكون هنالك توافق
حول حكومه مؤقته في فتره زمنيه معينه يتم
ايضا من خلالها دمج جيوش الحركات المسلحه
في الجيش ومن بعد الخوض العمليه
الانتخابيه في تقدير هذا التصور سيكون
مقبول لدى الجميع لكن اي تصور خارج هذا
الاطار يتحدث عن ابقاء الاوضاع كما كانت
من قبل انا في تقدير السيده الرفض وسيكون
هنالك تعمد بمعنى ان الدعم السريع لن يقبل
بهذا الطرح الذي اتحدث عنه الان لان الدعم
السريع من خلال هذه الجيوش الضخمه من خلال
هذه
التواجد شبكه النفوس والعلاقات التي
انشاها استطاع انه يحقق ويبني امبراطوريه
اقتصاديه كبيره جدا امبراطوريه عسكريه
فبالتالي اذا تخلى محمد حمدان
عن كل هذه المكاسب والمغانم فبالتالي لن
يكون لديهم رصيد سياسي لانه ليس بحزب او
او تيار سياسه او حركه سياسيه ولن يكون
لهم وجود عسكري لانهم غير مستوفين للعمل
في المؤسسه العسكريه فكل هذه المخالف انا
في تقدير مخاوف حقيقيه جدا هي التي دفعت
هذه الحرب ان تكون حرب وجودها شكرا
المبادره الامريكيه او غيرها تراعي هذه
المخاوف وتقدم تطمينات وحلول الجذريه
للازمه السودانيه شكرا جزيلا من باريس
محمد تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي
السوداني وكان معنا من ميشيغن السفيره
سوزان بيج مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق للشؤون الافريقيه والمستشاره
السابقه للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى
السودان
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]